[Music]
[Applause]
whether he's tackling the latest
tick-tock challenge
[Music]
or sharing his thoughts on a fellow
canadian collaboration
i feel like it's a bit of a missed
opportunity i mean no one
thought about buble balls or buble
bits
michael buble is taking over tick-tock
with his hilarious videos something he
told jimmy fallon on the tonight show
last year that has him considering early
retirement and it's the most fun i think
i've i don't think i'm i'm not even a
tour anymore i just want to go you have
to but you just settled the big room so
let's just watch this tick tock video
about it
i hear the jokes i see the memes blue
blade coming out of the cave blue blaze
defrosting christmas is near um
do you guys ever wonder
why someone might spend that much time
in a cave
it's because i
batman
and if you're worried michael's going
back into his bat cave fret knot we're
about to get a whole lot more as the
canadian crooner has just announced his
latest single i'll never not love you so
to celebrate we dug deep into the et
canada archives to find some of our
favorite funny moments with one of our
favorite canadians
it's kind of cool that this is how we
get to do it now i i put on a jacket
[Music]
but i'm i'm not wearing pants
and
of course you're not do you want to see
what is okay so this dress looks
incredible right like it's a nice dress
i've got velour
pants on
and
my slippers
and also i just to make sure that we
don't go too crazy i've got running
shoes on
i've got the beautiful four-month-old
baby who
is um is she running it yeah no she's
this happy little
little oh god little fat little
beautiful little healthy little gorgeous
thing um but she wants boobs a lot yeah
and uh and then i've got two little boys
i got eli who's three and those five and
they just beat
out of each other constantly but that's
what you want though of course it's what
i want but literally i spend all day and
every day in like this weird zombie
movie
saying the same thing over going no
don't no no no i said don't grab that
don't oh
the most famous person in my phone
wow that's a really good question
i don't i i think if you say nobody
you're lying right because nile i'll
just talk about that yeah okay i'll tell
you i just talked to nowhere i got angry
with him he got angry on him yeah
because he so lives in the moment that
he whatsapps me and he goes hey brother
how you doing and i go hey now what's
going on man
nothing
i say let's say in the conversation
and it happened like four times so i
wrote back the other day and i said like
you know
good good talk
nice time
[Music]